I think she has nipple confusion I think  you have nipple confusion she's just not  doing it it should be easy and it's not  okay well I don't I don't know how to  she could cry I don't think so  do you think it's me meaning maybe she  doesn't like me  Merson no of course she likes you  absolutely she's beating yeah are you  sure yeah looks like huh she's doing it  she's doing it  I was not it  babe uh tears oh I cannot wait until I  can put on a dress  yeah and go out with my girlfriends  that's okay suture please oh you're done  maybe I'm I'm sleeping I am beautiful  how is being a mom  god it's so exhausting but the whole  situation it's not a big deal  god no I mean it's done let's wipe oh  he's down yeah  why don't we gonna watch oh my good look  at that one where you guys are sleeping  together  tie-dye shorts  why do you keep picking out nobody's  going to know hey no you have to stay a  peanut forever no you've reached your  max size